what would happen is 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
one in the debut season of the champions
we found out hi everyone and welcome to
the champion season one reunion show I'm
Kate Abdo here with some of the more
noteworthy footballers and of course
their managers from this season hello
everyone hi Joe say that's quite an
outfit it's very decorative if he's the
most decorative I am the most decorated
manager so I have to start by asking how
are things between you and Paul Paul and
I are good
last week we even made eye contact he
knows what I think of him he is very
talented
I just wanted me to focus I am very
focused I am focused on football I'm
focused on my rap career I'm focused on
my shoe deal I'm focused on my hair
commercials and focused on all of it
Luca looks like you've gone back to your
old look after your flat five makeover
well mostly so what did you learn from
that experience I learned that I'm more
like a messy type like let my football
do the talking you know I'm the best in
the trophy this year well we just spend
some time with Fellini it was actually
amazing was straight in this hair Kevin
de Bruyne er I understand you feel the
show portrayed you a bit unfairly made
you look simple do you stand by this
Kevin yeah I wonder if you're the only
one does anyone else here feel they were
portrayed unfairly I was made to look
like a mumbler when in fact I enunciate
quite clearly sorry and you are Harry
Kane captain of the three lions and one
very hot spur no wait a moment no you're
not you you're Matthew Crawley from
Downton Abbey it's dance it's actually
dance Stevens I'm the actor who played
Matthew Crawley and I'm in other things
you know I played Sir Lancelot in a
third night the Museum movie I could
keep stupid poor just like you yeah kick
your stupid ok um want to shift gears
now to rail with Ronaldo GaN who would
you say is the best player in Madrid
moi we run major it now who needs
Galactica's when you have galactic cost
oh please everybody knows you're just
jealous of me the real bad boy of La
Liga and you're jealous that we have a
real manager
no sorry oh I noticed you're still stuck
together
Sergio will you ever apologize to mo and
just end this curse already I will never
apologize for Who I am sorry more at
this point I understand you will always
be a douche and I accept that now one of
the unfortunate things about having over
800 people in a house is that we can't
feed to everyone we heard a lot from
Galatasaray fans that they were hoping
to see their club so let's bring out
selcuk in an Afghan attire I come on out
Selter hi selcuk tell me how was your
Champions League season going not great
well that's all very exciting let's move
on to Delhi Ali I hear you're working on
a New Delhi Ali challenge wait a minute
we're all the Tottenham guys before you
said you could take his Omari yeah Harry
take us back to the mansion for the
knockout stage not if I take in Tyrone
first only the do is beat me
oh well that's definitely not the right
way wait this is not dimension well get
used to it because this is your new home
now
welcome to your Europa League it's not
so bad here but it's also not so good
[Music]